this year i didn't have to throw that
christmas party at a restaurant because
of covet
but we all went on zoom i never saw
ronnie
on zoom before but holy [ __ ] does he
have diarrhoea of the mouth my god he
comes to life
oh my goodness what it was is you would
get switched into different rooms
so like i'd be talking with jd and will
or somebody in a room
and then all of a sudden it would switch
and whenever i ended up in ronnie's room
i got to admit it was weird i mean it
was wild
just having a good time man as always i
gotta play you some of this
you gotta hear ryan had a few drinks in
me you know i'll skip to the end of the
night where ronnie's really into it
what you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna
cry [ __ ]
to the [ __ ] hospital what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
guys
the only thing that breaks through is
ronnie going [ __ ] you [ __ ]
who are you yelling at me i don't i
don't even remember
yeah i was amazed like at what people
ordered
jason had sushi coming to the house the
sushi order for some reason didn't make
it there he ordered a hundred dollars
worth of papa john's food
tell robin what you ate that night papa
john's yeah well yeah
so 10 minutes before the party started i
get this notice this uh text from the
restaurant saying they were cancelling
the order the snow's too bad i guess or
whatever so they weren't sending it out
he got
he got two pizzas one included listen to
this a cheeseburger topping
in other words ground beef and american
cheese and pickles and ketchup on it and
i have to say pickles on the pizza were
really good i uh
i have been turned on something new
well how much sushi had he ordered if
he's got a hundred dollars of papa
john's
well so i had 100 so i got one of those
like sushi boats you know for two people
you know
like 50 60
when you order performance
i would like a boat you know
and they probably deliver like 50
plastic forks and spoons because they
think they're serving like a for the
boat
i have had that before i've ordered food
and they sent me plates like i was
throwing a party for people
the other weird thing i thought at the
zoom christmas party was i got a good
look at um
jd and his wife and it's always weird to
see jd sitting next to a real live girl
and like trapped like
she attractive a conversation yeah she's
the talker
yeah i said that so jd just sits next to
her and she does all the talking
yeah he was so trashed he couldn't even
talk yeah you know we got a couple
bottles of wine so i
drank awfully quickly so yeah all you do
at the christmas party you noticed was
like you just laugh at ronnie the whole
time you're just like oh yeah i mean
what else are you gonna do
you can't talk you're not gonna get a
word in mind i'll just laugh at you oh
stop it
you